[Music]
hi everyone I'm profile and I'm a
product manager on Google Play incenting
it is so good to see you all here and
thank you for making it to the last
session of the day last year here at i/o
we announced Android instant apps and we
made them available to all app
developers today I'm very happy to
announce that we are extending the same
platform to all game developers as well
we call it Google Play instant where all
app and now game developers as well can
build instant native experiences for
their users in this session today we are
going to talk about two things one how
app developers across different app
verticals are finding success with
Google Play instant and two how easy it
is to get started if you want to build
an instant app tomorrow there is a
similar session focused on game
developers which I highly encourage you
to attend so let's talk about apps our
users they love native apps be it
watching video favorite TV shows or
having a smooth checkout experience
while shopping or buying flight tickets
it is not a surprise then that users
spent 87% of their mobile time in apps
compared to only 13% in apps one would
imagine then that if users are spending
so much time in apps then they must be
finding and installing lot of cool new
apps
well it's quite the opposite the same
report shows that
more than half of the user installed no
apps in any given month why well app
discovery is hard as app developers you
all can relate to the fact that getting
uses to find your app is filled with
huge challenge and after that for users
installation is another challenge to
understand these challenges better
we ran several user studies and we found
that the process of installation is
filled with friction questions and
concerns let me share with you some of
the actual quotes from our users apps
they take up space on my phone and my
phone run slower said one of our users
if I'm just ordering pizza I don't want
to have to download an app said another
many of them say that installation it
feels like more steps between me and the
information that I want and at Google
Play instant we totally relate to these
concerns and have been working hard to
remove these steps between users and
apps before we deep dive into details
and look at how let's first see instead
of inaction
[Music]
yes that's the magic of Google instant
and you can experience it from almost
any Android device that is running
lollipop or above in fact thanks to our
OEM partners such as Samsung Sony LG and
others we have now enabled more than 1
billion devices to run instant apps and
with all these devices enabled we have
expanded the discovery of your app too
well beyond Play Store so let's look at
some of the example in more detail
search one of the most powerful
discovery surface in this example our
early partner realtor has enabled
majority of their URLs to launch an
instant app so that when user taps on
any of the search URL they land right
into this fluid immersive experience
adds another great discovery surface
when user sees an ad of this interesting
game such as clash well they don't need
to worry about installing the game first
with one tap they can start playing this
immersive feature rich came right from
wherever they are
but discovery of your app does not need
to be limited to traditional surfaces
like search or web in this case the
third example one of our media partner
wiki was in the crowd today
notice that Lord of their users were
finding the content that they offer in
Play Movies app but once user find the
content they hit the same install
friction it was no brainer for them to
start replacing the install wiki button
with watch on wiki button so that in one
tab you
this can start watching the content that
they were after so we saw how instant up
improves the discovery of your app and
make your native app available to more
and more users but sitting in the crowd
you might be thinking all that is fine
but how is this going to help me Drive
installation that I really want well
that is where instant app really shine
let me show you how let's say your
friend recommends you a cool shopping
app father you find the app in the Play
Store and it does really look
interesting but wait a minute this is
also the moment where the commitment
anxiety kicks in we've all been there we
ask ourselves questions like do I really
need to install this right now is this
gonna give me all this stuff that I'm
after
why gotta do window shopping as I do in
real life well and a lot of users try to
do that window shopping by installing
and then uninstalling they don't need to
do that anymore once you publish your
app is an instant app we immediately and
automatically enable the China button in
the Play Store for e-commerce apps this
is indeed like window shopping for games
app this is a great way to play a game
before you decide to install and our
users they love this no commitment
option as an outcome some of our
partners are seeing installation of left
up to 19 percent while exact uplift
depends on many factors one thing is
very clear china removes commitment
anxiety and engages users who were
hesitant to install your app in the
first place
so if you want to start simple with
instant apps and if installation uplift
is the how you define your success then
journey is straightforward we will show
later in this session that with few
lines of configuration changes you can
enable the China experience for your app
as well but once you have an instant app
it does not need to be limited to the
China button in the Play Store the same
instant app can be launched from a
banner on on your website and as we talk
about banner first let me let me ask you
a quick question a quick show of hands
if you have come across a banner that
asked you to install an app on a website
well that's quite a lot of you and they
are indeed very common but the install
button on these banners it triggers the
same commitment anxiety can our users
experience the app just like try now
before the decide to install no points
for guessing that because of course they
can the instant app can change the web
to our banners to web to instant up
banners the install button can now be
replaced by Open button and in one tab
user can land into this immersive
experience delivered by the instant app
that you built and as you see on the
last image on the right they still have
option to install but there are no added
benefits one users have already
experienced your app so they are more
informed and to you as the developer
control the look field positioning
timing of this installation and you can
really integrate this world with your
user journey
some partners have reported that the
installs that they get from instant app
are more valuable to their business than
they install that they get organically
so we saw how instant app expands the
discovery of your app to new surfaces
like search ads and more we also saw
that how try now and web banners can get
you started
super quickly and give you installation
uplift that you want but beyond
discovery and installation we are always
working with all of you to unlock
critical user journeys for your app one
such feature we are launching is
notifications in beta for many user
journeys notifications are key extension
of your app functionality when your cab
arrives when your food gets delivered or
when your package ships I'm very happy
to announce that with this notification
beta and program we can start unlocking
those core use journeys and you can sign
up for this beta program using the URL
displayed on the screen 0 2 slash
instant ABS slash notification we would
love to learn and implement some good
use cases for notifications so in
summary we strongly believe that once
your Android app is instant the
potential and possibilities are
unlimited let me leave you with a video
of one such possibility where one of our
partner tap cart is building an
augmented reality shopping experience
right from the search results after the
video my colleague Raj will come on the
stage and share with you many success
stories that we are seeing with our
instant our partners thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome thank you for for thank you
everyone for being here today my name is
Raj ad Ramat and I'm a product
specialist for the Android platform here
at Google Play today I'm going to walk
you through a lot of the business impact
that we're seeing with developers that
are launching instant apps and hopefully
inspire you guys to also build an
instant app as well it's been incredibly
exciting to see all the different types
of instant apps that have been launching
since we announced in synapse last year
across all the different categories in
the store though we've actually seen
some really interesting and immersive
experiences coming from a few particular
categories including travel and local
e-commerce games and media including
things like video audio and news now the
common thread amongst a lot of these
different verticals is that all of these
partners are delivering extremely rich
immersive and native experiences to
their users for example if I'm searching
for a weekend getaway and I want to be
able to take a look at the house that I
want a book or watch a video or take a
virtual tour it's really great to do
that in a native experience quickly and
then be able to book or perhaps I'm
actually trying to buy something and I
want to take a look and see if it
actually fits on me as well like you saw
with that top cart video or if a friend
shares with me a link so that he can
play with me and see which player is
actually the best player
for a particular game I don't want to
have to wait to go to the store and
install I can start playing in that
particular moment and of course if a
friend shares a link to a video and we
want to be able to laugh about a
particular thing I can do that quickly
without having to wait for a page to
load or an app to install across all
these experiences we want to empower
users to have a frictionless checkout a
frictionless login and a frictionless
experience now I'm really happy to see
the business uplift that we're starting
to see from all of our partners and we
can generally categorize that uplift
across three different areas including
installs conversion and engagement let's
dive a little bit more into the installs
number so what's been really striking
for us since we launched Google Play
Instant is the fact that many partners
are actually seeing a huge boost to
their organic installs by launching an
instant app one of our partners nos
Donnell a Dutch News company actually
saw a 30% boost in installs by launching
their instant app another partner of
ours realtor.com real estate the company
based here in the US actually saw a 13
percent boost in installs from instant
apps let that sink in for a second
instant apps is now a major source of
installs for your business simply put if
you're not deploying an instant app
right now you're actually losing out on
installs and it's affecting your overall
user acquisition strategy we really
can't stress this point enough and we
want to make sure you understand that
there's gonna be ways where you can
drive more users to come to your app as
a result of Google Play Instant now
thinking about conversions we actually
saw from one of our partners we go that
they saw 27% increase in conversions
from their instant app we go is a flight
search engine based out of Asia and as
you saw from earlier Haller one of our
e-commerce partners actually saw a 20%
in
and conversions overall now that they
are both seeing success
we're actually advising both partners in
ways in which they can drive more
traffic to their instant app so they can
continue to capture that increase in
their conversions when we spoke to one
of our media partners Vicki a popular
Asian TV drama app they actually saw
monetizable watch time increase almost
5x from 9 minutes to almost 47 minutes
that's a huge increase in the amount of
time that they're getting from users
where they're able to capture them and
make them extremely loyal users overall
and what they're also reporting to us is
that the users that are downloading and
installing from their instant app are
actually much more impactful and much
more loyal users they subscribe more
they watch more and they register more
often I want to take a moment here and
deep dive into one of our partners
success stories as you know vimeo was
one of our first instant app partners to
launch their a video platform for
creators to post videos when they first
launched they actually saw engagement go
through the roof they saw over a hundred
30% increase in engagement compared to
other channels that means they were
capturing some serious power users
through their instant app when we also
worked with them to get their instant
app out the door they found that they
only had about 50% of their URLs enabled
for search which meant that there was a
opportunity to actually drive more users
from those URLs that are indexed already
to their instant app and today they're
actually at about 80 percent of their
URL coverage in 2018 what is the result
of all those efforts they're now
actually seeing almost 15% of their
installs coming from their instant app
and again our goal is to try and see how
we can continue to drive even more
traffic so that they can continue to
capture all of these users no matter how
you cut the data across all these
verticals and across all these
experiences
you're simply just seeing more installs
more conversions and more engagement I'd
like to now hand over the stage to my
colleague Ignacio who's gonna walk you
through all the ways in which you can
actually implement these features to get
your instant app launched Thank You ash
hello everyone my name is Ignacio Blanco
and I'm an engineering lead on the
Google Play instant team you heard from
Raj and Bravo developers are finding
success with instant apps what I'm going
to show you now is how simple it is to
prevent some of these features as well
as how easy it is to enable this success
for your instance I will cover three
stages of development
first how you reduce your app size so
your app can be instant second enable
traffic how you can make your app be
directly launched by your users and
third measuring success how your happy
users can drive up the metrics you care
about let's talk about reusing your app
size in order for an app to be instant
it needs to be small but we heard from
your developers that reducing app size
is really really hard
however there are today 100 megabyte
installable labs that have an instan app
we're going to walk you through three
techniques that you can use to reduce
your app size configuration apk is the
Google Play call library and the 10
megabyte program with configuration in
the case you just need to make a few
config changes on Gradle and you can
save significant amount of size on your
apk the way configuration apks work is
by partitioning your native code and
resources across locales abis and
densities additionally we are opening up
today the Google Play Khan library with
the Google Play code library you can
download on demand features on runtime
at runtime
what this allows you to do is to build a
small entry
experience and then download up to ten
extra megabytes on the background now
this two technique should be sufficient
for the majority of developers however
we are also opening up today a 10
megabyte program in beta what this
allows you to do is to build instant
apps that have a 10 megabyte entry point
so if you're interested please go to G
dot Co / instant ABS / 10 MB what this
will give you is try now immediately as
well as be blinking from your website
now if you are following the keynote
yesterday and the presentations you may
be wondering if this is related to the
Android app bundle and you're right
the Android bundle allows you to build
smaller apps opens a lot for
mobilization and helps you download
features on demand so no matter where
you're coming from
whether it is feeds by adopting the
Android bundle or building your first
instant app we got you cover tools on
the commentation will be available
shortly to guide you through the path so
I just show you how you can reduce your
app size now let's talk about how you
can enable traffic to go directly to
your instant app I'm gonna show you two
simple things on how you can get traffic
to be sent directly to your instant app
first is how you can enable the try now
second I'm going to show you how you can
get this web to up banners that Praful
talked about so when we launched right
now last October developers have been
enabling these by simply adding to your
under manifest a metadata tag with a URL
that points back to the instant app you
have your main launcher and a meta tag
this provides you try now that you have
been seen so far now to make it even
simpler and also to support partners
that don't have web presence like games
we were one step forward and we totally
remove the need for URLs as well as for
acid link verification so this is your
manifest now
without try now what you have to do is
simple nothing so starting today we
remove the need to have URLs in your
manifest at all you can publish an
instant out without any URLs if you do
this you immediately get try now as well
as the web to up banners so earlier in
the top raffle show you about show you
this web to up banners and ask if you
have seen them and you said yes but he
didn't show you was how we see it is to
implement them get ready
done just a pen launch it was through to
the live link on the Play Store and if
you have an instant AB those banners
will now take the user to the new
journey where from the open button they
just learn directly on the instant app
so far we covered reducing your up size
and in living to simple traffic sources
which are really powerful the next step
is how you can measure the performance
and the success of your instant app I'm
gonna walk you through two tools that we
had and we have extended to support
instant apps they will play console and
the Google search console one of the
questions that developers usually ask us
is how many installs is my instant up
driving well we have built this on the
Google Play console and you can access
this today simply go to statistics
configure your report select the
internet metrics you care about such as
launch and conversion events and finally
if you care about which refer is sending
traffic to your instant app select refer
platform the results really good my app
or number one is getting 150,000
sessions just between April and May
number 2 you see that the ad campaign
that we set up on April 18th is also
doing pretty well more launches are
drawing more installs just from instant
apps now if you want to see which
specific traffic source from the ones
that perform what talk about such a
search
browsers or try now is helping us here
what you see is huh try now is
effectively giving me 80% of my installs
just for my instant app now what I just
show you should help you understand the
performance of your instant app from the
Google Play console side if you are
integrating with Google search we have
also work with the search team to give
you these kind of stats what you see
here is the overall performance of your
search integration with your instant app
you can see clicks impressions an
average CTR you may also be wondering
which specific queries or which specific
URLs are driving traffic to your insta
nap we build that - down in the bottom
you can switch between queries and pages
and that will give you that fine detail
of impressions clicks and CTR for both
queries and URLs this should help you
further to understand your search
integration so to summarize what we
cover today is how you can reduce your
app size by using configuration apk is
how you can download on demand features
using the Google Play call library and
finally we talked about the 10 megabyte
program we didn't talk about enabling
traffic for your instant apt to try now
as well as some deep links and finally I
show you how you can understand the
success of your app from both the Google
Play console as well as they will search
console I want to thank you all of you
for being here please visit us at this
sandbox 10th see tomorrow enjoy the rest
of our and have fun at the concert
[Music]